in a very important match Fabiano
caruana and Hikaru Nakamura will face
off to decide the winner of Norway chess
in anticipation Hikaru had this to say
about their perceived rivalry I mean
rivalry I think it's too strong where I
think we all know each other too well at
this point I mean competitors I think
it's the way of putting it so he says
you're not Rivals just simply
competitors
what's the difference I don't know
it was an American showdown between
Bobby and Wesley today that set up
tomorrow's dramatic final round their
classical game was an accurate draw and
the Armageddon was looking to be a
similar story until Wesley blundered
with Pawn takes E4 from there Fabi
activated his attack one check led to
another Wesley's pieces fell a forced
mate was creeping its way to light
that's when so resigned allowing Fabi to
claim victory and a big lead in the
tournament only one person now stands in
the way Hikaru in the final round Hikaru
can intercept Fabi with a classical win
and so